It's become strangely normal
to tell our kids that they're going
to die from climate change.
If sea-level rise doesn’t get them,
then a wildfire will,
or a global famine, or crop failures.
Maybe a fatal heat wave,
the insect apocalypse
or the fishless oceans.
These are the headlines
we've all been told will be
the end of humanity.
So we shouldn't be surprised, then,
that young people today
feel crippled with anxiety.
A large international survey
asked 10,000 young people
about their attitudes to climate change.
More than half said
they think humanity’s doomed;
three-quarters find
the future frightening;
and more than one in three are hesitant
to have children of their own.
Young people today truly feel
like they could be the last generation.
In fact, prominent activist groups
actually take on this very name.
Now I get this feeling,
I've been there.
I used to feel like humanity was doomed,
and despite having multiple
environmental degrees,
I felt completely helpless
to do anything about it.
But I'm a data scientist,
and after years poring over the data
on how far humanity's come
and how quickly things are now moving,
my perspective on this has changed.
I think we've got
this framing upside down.
Far from being the last generation,
I think we will be the first generation:
the first generation to be sustainable.
When we think about sustainability,
we might imagine humans have only become
unsustainable in the very recent past,
that our ancestors lived
in perfect balance with nature
and only recently
has that been knocked off.
Unfortunately, this is not true.
If we're nostalgic for sustainable
paths to rewind back to,
there is none.
The world has never been sustainable.
Now I get that that's
a controversial statement,
so let me explain why.
When we think about
the definition of sustainability,
we might imagine something like this:
"having a low environmental impact
to protect future generations."
And it's true, by this definition,
many of our ancestors were sustainable.
They did have a low environmental impact.
But the reason they had
a low environmental impact
is because the populations were tiny.
And the reason their populations were tiny
is because half of children died
before reaching puberty.
Half of children died.
That, then, raises the question:
Is that what we really think
sustainability is?
Is that the world we want
to maintain and preserve,
one where half of our children die?
Hope your answer to that is no.
If we care about human suffering,
we need to add another dimension to this.
We need to also provide a good life
for everyone today.
Now that gives our definition two halves.
If we fail on either half,
we have failed to be sustainable.
That's where our ancestors
were never sustainable.
They never achieved
the first half of the equation.
And over the last few centuries,
the world has made
amazing progress on the first half.
As we've shown at Our World in Data,
child mortality is now down
to four percent.
Extreme poverty used to be the default,
now less than one in 10 people live there.
Literacy and education used to be rare;
now, most children in the world
get the opportunity to go to school.
But the world as it is today
is still unacceptable.
It's unacceptable that millions
of children die every year,
that hundreds of millions live
on less than two dollars a day,
which is an incredibly low poverty line.
But pick almost any metric
of human wellbeing,
and you'll find that the world
has become a much better place.
But that progress has come at a cost.
It's come at a cost to the environment.
We burn wood and fossil fuels for energy.
We expanded farmlands
at the cost of forests,
and our insatiable appetite for meat
means we now use half
of the world's habitable land for farming.
We kill billions of animals every year.
These are the trends
that make us feel doomed.
We see these lines rising,
and we assume they might never stop.
But more recent data tells us
a slightly different story.
A more hopeful story,
that we can turn things around.
This is per-capita CO2 emissions
in the UK since 1750.
Over the last few decades,
emissions in the UK have halved.
That means that my carbon footprint today
is less than half that of my grandparents'
when they were my age.
That's despite the fact
I live a much more extravagant lifestyle,
or, as they'd put it,
"You youngsters just don't know
how good you've got it these days."
(Laughter)
Now, you might think
the UK's cheating here.
It used to be this industrial powerhouse,
now it gets China, India and Bangladesh
to produce its stuff for it.
Maybe it's just offshored
all these emissions.
There's a bit of truth to this --
when we adjust for trade,
emissions in the UK are higher --
but we still see this dramatic decline
over the last few decades.
Offshoring is a bit of the story,
but it's not the entire story.
At the same time,
the UK has increased its GDP.
GDP has gone up,
while emissions have come down.
And it's not the only country
to achieve this.
You will see the same
for the US, for Germany,
France, Spain, Portugal.
A long list of countries
have increased GDP
while reducing their emissions.
And again, this is not just
because they've offshored them.
The notion that economic growth
has to be incompatible with reducing
our environmental impact
is simply wrong.
Now rich countries
are reducing their emissions,
but low- and middle-income countries
are increasing theirs.
What does this mean at a global level?
Well, total CO2 emissions
are now beginning to flatline,
but actually, emissions per person
already peaked a decade ago.
That means the emissions
of the average person in the world today
have peaked, and are now falling.
And we will see a peak
in total CO2 emissions soon.
Now, why is this happening?
A big driver has been
technological change.
Here, we see coal production
in the UK since 1700.
Now the UK was the birthplace
of industrial coal,
and it has now died there.
When I was born,
more than half of the UK's electricity
was coming from coal.
This is now less than two percent.
And it’s dying
in many other countries too.
You will see the same
for the US, Germany, Denmark, Spain,
Portugal, Greece, Ireland.
In many countries in the world,
coal is dying.
Taking its place are renewables,
where costs are plummeting.
The cost of solar has fallen
by 99.8 percent since 1970,
fallen by 90 percent
in the last decade alone.
And if you're worried that it looks
like this price trend is leveling off,
don't be.
When we zoom in, we see
that the price of solar continues to fall.
And the same is true for wind.
Go back a decade,
and solar and wind were among the most
expensive energy technologies we had.
That is why the world
was not making progress,
that is why countries
were not deploying them --
they were far too expensive.
But just ten years on,
and that script has flipped.
In many countries in the world,
solar and wind are now the cheapest.
Now if we're going to have renewables,
we're going to need energy storage.
But there's good news there too.
The price of batteries
has fallen by 98 percent since 1990.
If you take the battery
you'd find in a Tesla today,
go back to 1990, it would have cost
one million dollars.
It now costs just 12,000.
That’s completely transformed
the world of energy storage
and completely transformed
the world of transport.
Global sales of petrol and diesel cars
have already peaked --
they peaked in 2017,
and they are now falling.
Taking their place are electric cars,
where, in a space of just a few years,
sales are going through the roof.
And from energy and transport
to the food we eat,
you might imagine
that global deforestation
is at its highest level ever.
But actually, global deforestation
peaked decades ago
and is now falling.
But actually, it's better than that,
because many countries
are now regrowing their old forests,
such that the net decline
is even more impressive.
Now, why is this happening?
A big driver has been
increases in crop yields.
For all of our agricultural history,
crop yields were low and stagnant.
Farmers had basically
no opportunities to increase them.
Over the last century,
across many countries
and many different crop types,
crop yields have skyrocketed.
Here, we see it for the US, for corn,
where yields have grown sixfold,
from two tonnes to 12 tonnes.
Now what this means
is we can grow a lot more food
from a lot less land.
The amount of land
used to produce corn in the US
has not increased in over a century,
but look at the change in corn production.
My main point here is that in the past,
human progress had to come
at the cost of the environment.
If we wanted energy,
we had to burn wood
or we had to burn fossil fuels.
If we wanted to grow more food,
we had to expand farmland,
often at the cost of forests.
But technology and innovation
means we're very quickly
decoupling these impacts,
such that this conflict is no longer true.
Let's then think about the world
that we can have.
We need to achieve
the first half of our equation.
We need to end global poverty.
And here, I'm not talking
about raising everyone
above a two-dollar-a-day poverty line.
That is simply not good enough.
We need to provide everyone
with a good, comfortable life.
No child should die
from a cause that’s preventable.
Every child should get the opportunity
to go to school and get an education.
At the same time, we need to peak
and reduce our CO2 emissions;
we need to move away from fossil fuels;
and we need to end deforestation,
while feeding eight, nine,
ten billion people, at the same time.
How do we do that?
How do we become the First Generation?
First, our low-carbon technologies
need to become the default.
There's two ways to do this.
The first is to make sure
that they are affordable,
to make sure that they are
the cheapest option.
Solar and wind are already
cheaper than coal,
electric cars will soon be
cheaper than gasoline,
and alternative proteins
need to be cheaper than meat.
The other way to do this
is to make sure
these technologies are better.
Environmental products have often been
promoted as this happy gimmick,
but they need to go mainstream,
and for that, they need to be better
than the high-carbon alternatives.
Now my brother
recently got an electric car.
He didn't get an electric car
because he really cares
about the environment.
He does not want to be
the next Greta Thunberg.
And he definitely
does not want to be like me.
(Laughter)
He got an electric car because the design
and the driving experience
were far better
than the petrol alternatives.
That is how we make
low-carbon technologies the default.
We need to reframe the way
we talk about sustainability
as often promoted as a sacrifice.
Environmental messaging
is often built on scarcity.
It’s about reducing our lives
back to the bare minimum
and no more.
But this is not a vision
that inspires anyone.
This is not the future we want to build.
We need to reframe sustainability
as an opportunity,
because it is an opportunity.
It's an opportunity to provide clean,
abundant energy for everyone,
whether that's powering
cities or countries,
or getting rural communities connected
for the very first time.
It’s about not being at the whims
of fossil-fuel markets
or having millions
plunged into fuel poverty
when dictators invade
neighboring countries.
It's about breathing clean air.
Here, we see the decline
in harmful air pollution in the US,
from 2005 to 2021.
Stopping people from dying
is not a sacrifice.
Finally, it's a way to rethink
the way we live our lives,
the way we design our cities
and our communities.
Here, we see Copenhagen,
with bikes on the road,
or Amsterdam,
where you have
layer upon layer of bike rack.
Now I'm not saying this is how
our cities have to look.
We can design them in any way we want.
What I'm saying is that sustainability
gives us the shelf
to rethink the way we do things.
Finally, we need to rethink
the way we use data.
As a data scientist,
I take this very seriously.
The environmentalists
have done an amazing job
of waking the world up to these problems.
Those charts of rising CO2
and rising temperature
have been absolutely critical.
They're why I'm on the stage today,
they're why I got involved
in this in the first place.
But there's a limit.
When that's all we see,
we become paralyzed.
We see these lines rising,
and we assume that they might never stop.
We assume that no progress has been made,
that nothing good is happening.
But as we've just seen,
this couldn't be further from the truth.
We need to use data to inspire,
to show what the problems are,
also what the solutions are,
and we need to show real signs of progress
from countries, individuals, companies.
Historically, our sustainability
equation went like this.
It was one or the other.
You could not have both at the same time.
We can be the first generation
that does achieve both.
Now the emphasis here is on "can."
None of this is inevitable.
It's not even inevitable
that we'd have this opportunity
in the first place.
We're only here
because of the relentless work
of environmentalists, activists,
scientists, engineers,
entrepreneurs, communicators,
determined to make
the world a better place.
They have brought us here,
and we need to take that forward.
We need to do it bigger,
and we need to do it much, much faster.
But we do have the opportunity
to be the first generation
that builds a sustainable world.
Let's take it.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)